Today I want to talk about about the Russian revolution.
Um,
and so I want to do just a couple of things at the beginning and then I'm going
to,
um,
and I hope you weren't in Jay's class,
uh,
the age of total war last year because I gave the almost the same much or in it.
In fact,
I might've done it this year too,
because you know,
as you know,
I have him coming in and he has me go into theirs.
But what I want to do is see the revolution through the eyes of,
um,
of Nicholas and Alexandra,
uh,
for the last,
the last part,
but first,
just a couple of things.
Uh,
at the beginning,
um,
picking up on something that,
that I said when we talked about 1848,
but the Russian revolution is a perfect way to see revolution as process at
work,
uh,
because you're the revolution in February when we read the chapter,
the revolution of February is,
as I said before,
uh,
people wake up and they're not a lot of troops around and people are hungry and
the,
and the,
and the revolution.
False.
I mean the,
uh,
I don't talk more about this in a minute.
The autocracy a false,
uh,
rather quickly and rather easily.
And it's at that point when you got the provisional government of Koretsky,
it's at that point that as an 1848 and as in 17,
89 and following years,
that people who want to shape the future of the country put in their claims.
And so that's when social and political conflict increase,
uh,
dramatically in the context of the wars.
Of course,
I've just mind boggling,
uh,
with the front,
not all that far away from,
uh,
from pet,
from Petrograd because the Saint Petersburg was renamed petro guided at the
beginning of the war because it was more,
uh,
more Russian name.
And so those groups like dementia,
Vix,
when we read about the Bolsheviks who I lending comes back on the sealed train,
uh,
the liberals,
the cadets,
uh,
and those people who want to his Rs to a restoration,
and the socialist revolutionaries of which Kerensky was one,
uh,
who are,
who have the most influence in Russia,
have any dissident party by far.
And they would be allies,
especially the left wing of the socialist revolutionaries of,
um,
uh,
of the Bolsheviks after the Bolshevik seizure of power.
And then of course,
they're just dismissed,
uh,
and,
you know,
persecuted,
like it light,
like the others.
Uh,
uh,
but they all put forward their claims.
And so all of the kinds of tensions and the,
the Corner Law Firm,
uh,
in quotes,
plot,
uh,
which you can read about and the July days and all of that really reflect the
revolutionary process.
And of course,
what happens in,
in,
um,
uh,
in,
October is the Bolsheviks,
uh,
after one attempt that didn't work,
the Bolsheviks are able to seize power.
Uh,
and so Trotsky,
who ends up,
as,
you know,
with the ice pick planted,
uh,
through his neck in,
in a garden in Mexico City,
uh,
assassinated on the orders of stolen,
um,
and,
and learning.
And,
and,
uh,
and the very young,
Stalin who was in,
in jail,
uh,
I mean,
he's in,
he's in Siberia at the time of the February revolution.
Uh,
the Bolsheviks come to power and,
and,
uh,
the Soviet Union is created.
And a next week I'll talk about,
uh,
about Stalin and installing ism.
Uh,
but today it's enough to,
to talk about,
um,
about the Russian,
uh,
a revolution.
And so before I go back and,
and,
um,
tell you about a Alexandra and I about to Nicholas and Alexandra and,
and the crazed Rasputin,
uh,
and those folks,
um,
uh,
you know,
there it is.
Um,
you know,
nobody expected there'd be a revolution.
I,
the revolution,
the Marxist revolution or version would come to Russia.
Um,
that populace,
uh,
who in the middle decades of the,
of the 19th century,
believed that the Russian peasantry wasn't potentially revolutionary force.
I mean,
people like,
like Buck Union,
I'm whom I've talked about before,
you know,
they thought that the,
that the peasants would rise up one day and,
and,
uh,
sweep away their,
their masters,
uh,
who,
to whom they were,
uh,
indentured as serfs until 1861.
Now,
that's not that long before,
um,
uh,
before World War One and all of that.
But you know,
for marks,
I mean,
the revolution had to come where you had a class conscious proletariat that had
been organized by this,
a revolutionary elite,
sort of a top down,
organized,
revolutionary leap.
And,
and then that would come in in Germany,
uh,
in Britain,
you know,
in France,
eventually,
maybe in the United States.
And you know,
after the Bolshevik revolution,
uh,
you know,
Lennon is still convinced that the revolution isn't going to come in Germany.
Uh,
in fact,
the spartacists do rise.
There were a real far left revolutionary group full of some very good people
incidentally,
like Rosa Luxemburg who ends up being murdered.
I was born in south motion in,
uh,
in,
what then was,
was a Russian,
a Russian Poland,
uh,
you know,
they,
but,
uh,
the revolution was,
had to come where you had an industrial proletariat,
but it doesn't,
or does it?
So let me just Ben,
little ambiguous there.
But let me say that because the revolution starts in Petro God,
that the,
that the way petro God was in 1917 and administrative czarist autocratic capital
constructed by Peter the grade,
but also a huge,
enormous,
uh,
industrial center with hundreds of thousands of industrial workers.
Uh,
and the,
the historians still debate whether by October that is after February during the
provisional government time or the socialist revolutionaries or the Bolsheviks
had more influence in the Soviet.
That's where the Soviet Union comes from.
And the Soviet,
which organizations of workers,
uh,
sailors and soldiers.
Um,
but so,
uh,
I mean was Mark's,
Mark's wasn't all wrong about because the revolution that the role of industrial
workers in Saint Petersburg,
uh,
is,
um,
uh,
you know,
is very important in this.
And of course lots of them to get better.
I mean,
they all get betrayed ultimately because what was going to be,
you know,
the Worker's Paradise,
uh,
it ain't that and work herself management,
it didn't become that then become that at all.
And they're,
they're shocked when the,
you know,
when the,
the red guards are putting down their strikes.
But in the beginning,
the role of the workers in on the periphery member center and periphery is
terribly important.
And in,
um,
I mean,
I talk a little bit about this in what you're reading,
but you know,
along the Nevsky prospect,
you have,
you know,
government buildings,
you've got the singer sewing machine company.
Uh,
you know,
you got tramways I haven't been to Saint Petersburg in,
in a sense,
central told him to come.
Ohad does since,
you know,
since the f the fall.
But I mean re,
but a very fancy stores in,
in,
uh,
in 1917,
very dolled up people,
very rich people.
Uh,
uh,
and then the,
the,
the tramway,
I simply stopped in the mud when they reached,
uh,
the periphery when they reached their working class suburbs and the lights that,
you know,
the glittering lights of the big department stores that would make you think of
London and Paris and Berlin and Vienna,
uh,
and the big fancy hotels and all lit up with,
with the dorm and clicking their heels as the well heeled,
enter and leave.
Even during the war.
Uh,
you know,
the lights,
there weren't any lights when you got it or very few when you got into the
working class.
Uh,
suburbs.
So the,
the,
the one thing that to keep in mind is that,
you know,
the Russian revolution both that of February and that of,
of,
uh,
of October was a popular revolution.
This was no sort of coup d'etat,
you know,
carried out by,
uh,
a couple of extremely organized,
determined,
you know,
politicos and Lennon.
He was organized and he was determined.
Lennon was not with the French will call Rigo Lowe.
He was not a barrel of laughs.
Uh,
I,
he was sure of himself.
Uh,
uh,
he had very little sense of humor.
He had sarcasm,
biting sarcasm.
And I guess I quote once in there,
he said when he would argue with somebody who said he was not understand,
that understands nothing,
he was very,
very sure of himself.
Very Dif difficult man to get it.
Yeah.
I had to get along with,
uh,
and,
and they'll leave it to you to think was stolen ism inevitable.
And letting is,
I'm,
I'm not so sure it was,
but,
uh,
anyway,
but the revolution was a popular revolution.
I mean,
the,
the fall of the autocracy,
th th th th the,
the masters did not rise up to save the czar.
Okay.
They did not.
And there's our Heda and bread.
It'll land and peace,
bread,
land and peace is a very,
very,
uh,
important slogan when you've got New Orleans of people under arms from all of
the nationalities.
Okay.
Some of whom didn't know Russian at all.
Yeah.
Many of whom when they go into the war,
don't know the difference.
When a gun in a and a pitchfork,
uh,
and you know,
until the very end,
Nicholas and Alexandra who are not very lovable people,
one can feel sorry for them and you will feel sorry for them.
They ended horribly.
Uh,
but there was this sort of,
they still had the belief that,
that,
uh,
that the Russian people a love there's are,
and that they would pour forward to save the czar and the Zarina and the
autocracy,
uh,
and they didn't.
And then the treaty of breath,
the Tufts March,
1918 polls,
uh,
pulls Russia out of the war and all of that.
So that's just a couple of things at the beginning to the say in it and it's all
in the book,
but,
but it's,
um,
you know,
it's still,
it's a very interesting revolution.
There's a lot of great literature on the Russian Revolution in,
in English,
and I don't read Russian at all,
uh,
but in all sorts of languages.
So now having a,
just sort of set that up,
reserved seating,
VIP,
what is this?
This is,
yeah.
I don't know.
Anyway,
AH,
anybody there?
Nobody there.
So,
uh,
anyway,
um,
let's talk about,
did I do all that?
Yeah,
let's talk about,
uh,
Nicholas and,
um,
and the Alexandra.
Um,
hold on.
the Czar Nicholas was a family guy.
Okay.
Uh,
he enjoyed,
uh,
his family.
Uh,
they played tennis,
they were modern people.
They had bicycles.
Uh,
they pedaled around the bicycle was relatively,
you know,
recent invention.
As you know,
a,
the first big bicycle races in Europe are already in the 18.
I'm a nineties.
Uh,
but like his cousin Nicholas,
the second he had some general education,
I ended the political economy and math and geography,
uh,
in foreign languages,
which he spoke very well and in middle in military science,
but he had very little intellectual interest at all.
And built into the way he looked at the world was this,
uh,
this inherent suspicion of rationality of the enlightenment.
He would somebody who,
uh,
and his wife also would still blame if he discussed it.
Peter the great for having really incorporated in some ways rational
organization and the alignment,
uh,
at least the works of the philosophic,
into Russia.
A long before that,
he believed that war waging war was a matter of,
of,
of honor.
And in that he shared a lots,
uh,
with his,
a Wacko cousin,
Wilhelm.
The second,
um,
he was hardworking.
Uh,
he,
I in the sense that,
that he read,
he read or listen to reports on all of that was going on about the war.
Uh,
he,
uh,
Mark Steinberg has published some of the letters of,
of a mark Steinberg as a friend of mine who teaches at Illinois.
Um,
and if I remember correctly,
I,
he,
uh,
those are,
those are belief,
believed that,
that the nobles had compromised the fade of the autocracy.
Uh,
in some ways are threatened it by being,
being,
being indolent and not working hard enough.
His view was always that he was the father of his people,
uh,
that he was the Holy Azhar.
And again,
everybody's seen pictures of him standing as sitting on a horse blessing the
kneeling soldiers as they're going off to fight.
Uh,
in 1914 how he constantly referred to his ancestors.
The Romanovs only the state which preserves the heritage of the past is strong
and firm.
He wrote,
we are still selves have sinned against this and God is punishing us,
punting,
punishing us with,
uh,
the war.
He took command of the Russian army in 1915 against the advice of his wife.
He didn't usually go against the Weiss.
The advice of Nicholas,
I mean,
if Alexandra,
uh,
the advice of his ministers and the advice of the mad monk Rasputin uh,
obviously one of the reasons that people argued against this was a while.
I mean,
he really wasn't a military guy.
And B,
if he doesn't go well,
will people blame the czar?
Will the role of the czar,
uh,
be a diminished?
Um,
he had a strong sense of what he considered moral and it was shaped by,
uh,
his Orthodox,
religion.
His wife about whom I'll have more to say was a convert to Russian Orthodox.
He didn't like many converts from one religion to another.
Uh,
was,
uh,
absolutely fanatic in her,
attachment.
Um,
he was more relaxed about religion than his wife was,
but he often spoke about this or x to see,
uh,
religious ecstasy that he felt when he went,
at a church.
Um,
you know,
historians now say,
well,
it's too easy to shape a discourse about the Russian revolution around the
influence of Rasputin.
Uh,
but in fact,
I'm Rasputin in a,
in 1914 had worn that,
that that war would bring God's punishment,
uh,
upon Russia and great destruction and grief without end.
And,
you know,
Rasputin did have great influence with the family.
Uh,
in one letter,
um,
again,
this is mark,
uh,
put this stuff together.
He wrote,
um,
does our role,
when I am worried or doubt fuller vexed,
I've only talked to Gregory for a few minutes to fuel myself immediately,
suits and strengthened.
Now,
one of the reasons that Rasputin has so much influence on the royal family was
of course tragic illness because Alexi,
the sun was a hemophiliac and haemophiliacs,
um,
I guess now they can treat it easier than they could before,
but when hemophilia x get a scratch,
they can lead,
the blood does not clog you late and,
and you know,
they can die.
And so he was always sort of,
you know,
he was not in good,
uh,
a good,
good,
good health at all.
Um,
he and Rasputin on a couple of occasions got lucky and predicted the end of,
of a,
a spell as he used to call him,
or an episode,
uh,
of hemophilia a and everything worked out okay.
And so this increases the,
uh,
this is,
increases the belief of,
of these parents in,
uh,
in,
in the power,
if you will,
of of Rasputin.
And when there was a mutiny in the navy,
he wrote,
if you find me so little troubled,
it is because I have the firm and absolute faith,
the destiny of my,
of Russia,
of my own fate.
And that of my family are in the hands of all mighty God who has placed me where
I am.
Whatever may happen,
I shall bow to his will and this kind of fatalism you would see to the end when
after the revolution.
And he's on a train and,
and uh,
I,
you know,
he,
he doesn't,
he finally get you,
it has to turn back.
Uh,
but he doesn't,
he,
this is her fatalism was part of it.
And maybe Rasputin by then that,
that point was art was already dead.
He'd been,
he'd been,
he'd been assassinated.
And even the story of his assassination,
I mean,
he was almost impossible to kill him.
They kept hammering with huge rocks and pumping one bullet after another into
them.
Uh,
the people that want to get them out of the way.
And,
and,
and they finally,
after just sort of beating the hell out of and pumping one bullet after another,
uh,
into all parts of his body,
or they threw him into a lake,
weighted down with rocks.
And when they brought the weight,
uh,
the,
the body up and did an autopsy,
they found out that he died of drowning.
But in any way,
his,
his influence over the czar in a way create or helped a,
accentuated the,
this sort of fatalism,
uh,
that was,
almost predetermined.
You could say by this,
this,
uh,
his religious,
orthodoxy.
But if you're going to be the autocratic czar father of all the people,
you don't want any PR schickl any political institution that's going to limit,
uh,
your will.
Now the Duma,
uh,
the assembly had been created in 1905 after the revolution,
which I trust that you have,
have read about in 1905.
And the role of the Russell Japanese war in facilitating that,
he believed that even the existence of the Duma a would compromise,
uh,
the virtues of,
of the Toc crecy.
And as you know,
the,
the Duma loses,
loses what,
what,
uh,
most of what authority and had given,
um,
that,
that the Duma seem to be a rational organization.
And this didn't fit terribly when terribly well,
uh,
in a worldview that,
that,
uh,
that believes in faith,
feeling as opposed to reason a and has a particular,
uh,
in something that's peculiar idea of a,
of morality shaped by the traditions of,
uh,
of mother Russia.
Um,
and,
and he,
he and his wife to look back to this sort of imaginary time before Peter the
Great,
when the true Russia did not look westward at all and was not tempted by these,
these foreign imports imports.
Uh,
and he idealize that time of,
you know,
piety,
uh,
the unity between the czar,
and his people,
the Nahad.
Uh,
in 1902,
he wrote a letter to Alexandra when he was on tour.
He said,
we pass through large villages where the good peasants presented simple bread
and salt,
a vert,
which are very important in,
in Russia.
And his coordination,
they spilled the salt that was part of the ceremony.
And that was a bad omen.
He was very superstitious by the way.
17 was,
is unlucky number.
He was terrified of 17.
And at us,
there was a huge throng at his inauguration and a stampede and lots of people
were killed.
So that was a bad omen too.
But anyway,
he said,
uh,
all the peasants presented simple bread and salt and all went down immediately
on their knees showing such a touching,
touching,
childish joy.
Uh,
he had the image that the Russian people were childish,
uh,
that,
that they and his wife insisted on this,
that the,
that they loved being whipped.
They love being punished.
Now since the abolition of the surf term in,
in,
in 1861,
uh,
there was lots of mistreatment of peasants by,
by Lords,
but,
uh,
you could no longer torture,
literally torture a serf.
So long as,
as he didn't die and before 1861,
if you torture to surf and he did die,
or if you just exited them a ordered him killed or kill them yourself,
you receive a small fine.
Um,
but still there was this idea that,
that,
uh,
that the know and that the people of good quote unquote good,
virtuous and kindly will come to their senses and that they will not disobey
during the war.
They will do what he told them.
And until the end possibly,
we don't know this,
the idea that they will rise up and take him away from his captors in those
final days.
And they did try,
there were attempts,
but it wasn't the,
it wasn't ordinary people.
So,
um,
he had these views of orthodoxy,
autocracy,
aristocracy,
et Cetera.
It's a romantic view.
Uh,
he preferred Russian foods.
Um,
Peter the great like Russian food,
but he also remember ripped roasts off tables in,
in,
in London and,
and drink tons of wine and things like that when he was in a,
um,
uh,
you know,
in,
in western Europe.
Um,
he,
he spoke Russian obviously very well,
but he spoke English with his wife because English was her,
was her language,
uh,
you know,
along with,
with,
with some German.
Um,
and again,
uh,
speaking English was part of the kind of aristocratic tradition of speaking
other languages by the aristocracy,
but not,
not Russian,
because again,
French and German was,
you know,
they did speak Russian,
but French and German,
we're,
we're sort of privileged,
uh,
languages.
Um,
and he had his feeling that he didn't like big cities.
Uh,
he had his retreat on,
on,
on the scene there,
uh,
Saint Petersburg or petro God.
Uh,
he said that Moscow and Saint Petersburg were two needle dots on the map of our
country.
Well,
in terms of percentages,
uh,
he was certainly,
correct.
Uh,
and it was his idea to rename a Saint Petersburg a petro cloud because it was
more a Russian,
but he believed that,
uh,
and I've already spoken about this a little bit of that,
that the heart of the empire,
uh,
was,
was Moscow because it was a religious capital of the empire.
And that the skyline was dotted,
uh,
with,
with churches and not by a government,
uh,
buildings,
that,
uh,
part of having a modern army and a modern navy navy,
you had to have a bureaucracy and that,
uh,
petro rod was a bureaucratized city and not,
truly a Russian in its heart and its spirit.
And he didn't spend much time in the famous winter palace,
uh,
that of,
of the siege,
uh,
in the Russian a revolution.
And when he moved to his,
um,
uh,
when he,
when he went to his provincial,
uh,
a resort,
on the sea where I've been,
but a long time ago,
uh,
he had a new church built there,
but in the Moscow style,
the,
in the original Moscow style,
now Nicholas and Alexander Alexandra,
Huh.
Excuse me.
Were raving antisemites.
And that's why it's amazing.
This is business about,
you don't,
can't,
I don't know if they didn't,
they canonize them as a saint or something.
I really don't know.
But it's,
it's a,
that's horrific.
He loved the black hundreds who had sparked and,
and,
uh,
you know,
in the pool go home,
uh,
particularly in Crimea in 1905 and had beaten Jews to death.
He thought that they represented the true heart of,
of Russia.
Um,
his interpretation was that the pogrom were the pious rage.
I think that's Mark's phrase,
but not his,
but again,
here's his against,
and I unfortunately quote the Poles and the yields that is,
uh,
you know,
a slang,
uh,
horrible,
you know,
racist,
uh,
ethnic denunciation of people who happen to be Jewish who had agitated and
brought about the concessions of 1905,
that the revolution of 1905,
and until he went to his grave,
so to speak.
Uh,
he believed that the Russian revolution was the work of,
of Jews.
And incidentally,
because some,
some of the Bolsheviks,
a fair number of the Bolsheviks hadn't to be Jewish.
Uh,
this played into,
in the Russian civil war because of the,
uh,
the sheer brutality of,
in the Russian civil war of the quote unquote white forces against the reds are
the Bolsheviks,
uh,
was,
often,
uh,
part of,
you know,
just sort of extension of,
of,
uh,
of antisemitism,
run a wild.
Anyway,
Nicholas wrote that,
that,
uh,
that the deaths of these people of the Jews in 1905 was justified harm be fell
not only the kids,
but also Russian agitators,
engineers,
lawyers,
and all other bad people.
Uh,
and,
uh,
well anyway,
his,
I mean it's very sad,
but his,
there's lots of complexity built into his,
his,
uh,
he is being,
on one hand,
he's supposed to be the,
the tsar of all the people.
He's supposed to be ruthless.
He's supposed to be tough,
hard,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
but on the other hand,
he's dominated by his wife.
Um,
and,
uh,
his wife has constantly urging him in her letters to him to be harsh,
demonstrate quote,
the power of your will and your decisiveness show you're the complete autocrat.
Without whom,
quote,
Russia cannot exist.
Um,
my love when it lasts,
where you some with your hand upon the table and scream at those who act
wrongly.
They didn't not fear you enough,
but indeed they must.
Oh my boy.
Make one tremble before you to love you is not enough.
They must obey you.
Show to all that you are the baster and that your will will be obeyed.
He signed one letter to his wife,
quote,
ever your poor little Hussy.
That's an odd choice of word
with a tiny will with a tiny will.
She was born in Germany,
a princess,
and these royals,
as I've stressed,
they're all in our married.
She's the granddaughter of Queen Victoria of England.
Uh,
she had identity with Hessa,
[inaudible],
Stott,
the part of Germany in which he was born.
And as I said,
although she spoke English at home and with her children,
uh,
she had been a convert to Russian orthodoxy.
She also feared or resented idleness.
She,
uh,
thought it was important to work.
She was a nurse for her children.
She worked for her son above all.
She worked very,
very hard.
Uh,
she wanted to keep her daughter's quote from foolish gossip and a way from being
quote,
idle and list and listless.
She was fanatically religious.
You went to church every day and she was intolerant of those people who did not.
And again,
this turns them toward Rasputin.
Now again,
Rasputin did not make the bite by being who he was,
the Russian revolution.
It's a popular revolution,
but still,
you know,
he's there lurking in the shadows.
She said,
recipe Putin,
God has given rescue and more insight,
wisdom,
uh,
and,
enlightenment than all of,
uh,
the,
the czars advisers.
And at home,
she reinforces the ideas that any kind of compromise,
constitutional compromise,
uh,
was,
was dangerous.
And she believed that until the end,
that that Saint Petersburg petro cod was a rotten town,
not rushing at all.
And as for the black hundreds who had murdered all the Jews,
they represented a quote,
the healthy right thinking Russians,
the Russian people love to be whipped.
She said that was a quote.
Um,
she believed it was in the Slavic nature and they use over and over the world.
The word childish in describing the Russian people.
Um,
the Progressive Block,
uh,
which I sent around,
on,
uh,
on the website.
Um,
she believed that that the prayer,
the existence of the progressive block wood,
which we wouldn't have been really possible had it not been for war one.
That's one way world war one gives opportunity to Russian dissidents to get
together in ways that they couldn't have otherwise.
It makes possible,
uh,
the,
the operation,
the creation and operation of voluntary associations that are bringing people
together to try to send food and letters to the front,
uh,
to get news from the front that are not military secrets.
Eh.
And these inevitably began to think to imagine a world without the czar.
And there were people in 1905 who could imagine a world without the czar.
But again,
there are lots of people who are thinking about the postwar world and who
imagine or are planning beginning to plan for a reform Zara's.
Him,
it's very hard to say how many people,
uh,
could,
um,
comprehend the idea that Russia would not have a tsar.
Obviously the Mensheviks,
the socialist revolutionaries and the Bolsheviks,
uh,
did,
a fuel that way.
Uh,
but all,
you know,
all of these dissident groups want,
uh,
want change,
but only the liberals and particularly the cadets Kaa d ts whom you can read
about,
uh,
want,
the czar,
uh,
as armed autocracy to,
um,
uh,
to continue.
But until the very end,
Nicholas is determined to defend the awkward at the autocracy,
trying to transfer power to his brother when the revolutionary comes.
Michael,
who would be their reason for Alexi?
And then when told by his son's physician and imagine this,
that his son would not recover.
Uh,
he tried to leave,
uh,
the autocracy in the hands forever in his of his brother,
Michael.
Uh,
but,
uh,
in fact,
he abdicated the next day and he,
and he really wrote only,
um,
all around me is treachery,
cowardness,
cowardice,
uh,
and deceit.
Now what were they going to do with them?
What do you do with the czar of all the Russians and Alexandra and their
children?
Now predictably enough,
the liberals and the cadets want,
want to have them protected.
The Socialists,
basically one him,
uh,
to go on trial.
That is the Mensheviks,
the socialist revolutionaries and,
and,
and the Bolsheviks.
But for a couple of days,
they don't do anything at all.
I've made good other things going on.
Uh,
they've got the war and,
and that,
you know,
I won't discuss the attitude of the provisional government to the war and the
kinds of pressures from the allies of course,
for them to keep the war going.
Uh,
and that is,
is a,
is handled in,
uh,
handled it in textbooks in the textbook,
but there are more demands from,
from the public and from the Soviets in particular to arrest him.
And so the provisional government wants,
they want to protect them and they finally ordered them confined to the resort,
uh,
which is called Czar School Slo,
but the name doesn't matter.
Uh,
Nicholas himself,
he wants to go to Britain.
Uh,
and one day he wanted to live out the rest of his life with his family in
Crimea.
Now does the British government wants the tsar of all the Russian people to
arrive in London?
Not exactly a,
because it might complicate a,
the war effort and the Labor Labor will have no part of it at all.
And because you're dealing with a coalition in the war,
you can't have the czar,
you know,
the,
you're not going to be taking,
coming into seven 47 or something,
but,
uh,
you know,
you can't have him coming up the river and the,
and in the Tams.
And how are you going to get them there in the first place?
So that simply is,
is not,
um,
not,
uh,
practical.
Um,
and the liberals didn't want the czar there,
uh,
either,
but there were constantly rumors that the czar was going to be allowed to leave.
And,
and this,
uh,
there's lots of protests,
about that.
Uh,
Koretsky says that the,
the,
the revolution should show its moral worth by seeing that no harm came to the
royal family.
By the way,
just as an aside,
Kerensky lived a very,
very long life.
And at the end of his life,
he taught this course at Stanford University.
And there's a story,
there's probably Apocryphal,
uh,
that a student once,
this is in very contentious times in American politics in the late 1960s,
I can vaguely remember those days.
Uh,
and that a student not realizing what's Kerensky ask a question saying,
how could their provisional government and be so stupid,
you know,
in their conduct of,
of,
uh,
of those operations.
And,
and the,
the coolest person.
I had no idea that this was Koretsky,
you know,
who was an historian.
It was trained as an historian and he died shortly thereafter.
But that,
that is,
uh,
that is really,
it's amazing thing.
Of course,
Lenin dies in 1,924 or 25,
but Krinsky went on and on.
So what they do,
they're in the park.
I mean,
they're in the,
in,
in the resort.
Uh,
uh,
their little palace,
they're mini palace.
They're allowed to,
to,
to take walks.
They could talk on the telephone,
but only in Russian and only in the presence of a guard who spoke Russian.
They could not speak German or they could not speak English.
Um,
they separated the family for a while.
Fearful of the influence on,
on Alexon of Alexandra on,
uh,
I'm Nicholas.
No,
again,
this is rather like the attitude that people had towards [inaudible] net and
Louie the 16th cause people w uh,
uh,
thought that the influence I'm Ranta network.
It was a on with that,
it was overwhelming on,
uh,
on,
um,
uh,
I Louis the 16th.
Anyway,
then they were put back together and they didn't have much to do.
They gardened.
Uh,
they taught the children,
which they always had done.
They wrote letters,
they went to church and they complained that the soldiers were more and more
disrespectful.
They,
they,
they were noisy.
Um,
they were slowly in their dress.
Slovenly and their address,
they're crushed.
Caps were set awry on a huge mops of unkept hair.
Their coats were half buttoned and their nonchalant manner of performing their
military duties with a constant irritation and they mocked them.
Uh,
the knock on the door,
who's there and the answer,
who is there.
And the answer would come.
The czar of all the Russians and a Latvian guard,
uh,
I'm near a commoner in quotes outside would be laughing.
Uproariously once he was peddling this,
ours peddling his bike and he goes by a guard who was a band nat and the gay the
bay,
the guy sticks his bayonet into the spokes of the,
uh,
of the wheel and the tsar of all the Russians went tumbling down and skinned his
knees.
Uh,
but yet there were rumors how a well there were eating when nobody else was,
was eating.
Uh,
when,
uh,
the July days,
um,
uh,
many,
attempted revolution comes,
uh,
for their own safety.
Krantz he says they have to be moved.
And so they decided on a sub on Siberia,
so almost inevitably to a town called Tobolski where they're presumably be safe
and they were moved on the August 1st,
1917 with train their windows covered up for most of the trip.
Like Lennon when he comes back is brought back by Germany to help to encourage
the Russians to get out of the war.
He goes on the famous sealed train so people can't see that it is Lennon because
people knew what he looked like.
The same thing,
you know,
the tsar of all the people are not going to be seen by the masses because what
if they tried to stop the train and pull them off that,
um,
ironically they passed by Rasputin's home village and Adidas House as a steam
boat,
uh,
took them via two rivers to this town of,
of Toll Bosca where I have never been.
This frightened them because they're,
especially Nicholas is so superstitious,
you know,
the salt falling,
the Ma,
the stampede,
the number 17,
and all of this is that when either pulled by the house or,
uh,
on the,
on the steamboat of the dead Rasputin his trusted advisor.
It is a bad omen.
Um,
and so they could now they could go to church when they arrive.
They play cars,
they perform place and you all from me,
which they did,
uh,
a lot.
Uh,
but as the co,
the counterrevolution was a very real threat,
uh,
of course.
And of course the Americans and,
and,
uh,
the British and the French after the bullshit of revolution,
if you want one reason that's to Stalin in the,
was so paranoid and he's clinically paranoid just to complete,
you know,
uh,
dangerous crackpot,
but they had a lot to be paranoid about because the Americans and the British
and the French kept trying to,
you know,
Undo,
uh,
the Russian a revolution.
But anyway,
there were photographed and the ID cards,
I mean,
you can imagine the czar and there's arena having id cards like your Yale I id
cards.
Um,
and,
um,
they're,
uh,
they start seeing obscene graffiti written,
new guards come in that they were thought to be a,
that were,
uh,
had even less respect for him than the other people.
Uh,
there,
there are serious attempts to,
uh,
to,
to kidnap them and to,
to take them,
uh,
um,
to,
to get rid of them.
Uh,
there was one in which monarchists we're supposed to be hidden under the altar
of or czarist,
uh,
under the altar of the church,
you know,
when they're in the service.
And this,
again,
these throwback to the revolution,
it was like the in French revolution.
Uh,
there's a massacre starts at the,
at the,
uh,
the,
the festival of the federation,
uh,
when people are hidden under a,
under the church.
And so,
uh,
there are articles in the newspapers calling for the surveillance of Nicholas,
the bloody Romanov I,
and calls for him,
uh,
to be put on trial.
Um,
the arrival of a certain Vasily Jaco left the name,
uh,
you don't have to remember,
obviously sent by the central executive committee of the Soviets.
Uh,
he was a longtime revolutionary,
uh,
rumored subsequently to been an agent of,
of,
of the Germans with,
which is preposterous.
I mean,
Lennon was,
rent was rumored to have been an agent of the Germans by his enemies because of
the way he got back to,
uh,
to Russia.
Uh,
after the initial,
uh,
revolutions.
He was a sin,
uh,
of a peasant.
Uh,
he had that kind of,
um,
curriculum vitae,
uh,
that lots of folks,
including styling had.
Uh,
he,
uh,
had,
um,
uh,
participated in holdups armed holdups to raise money,
for,
uh,
a revolution and became,
became a Bolshevik,
uh,
he,
transferred the czar and family to a much a smaller place.
Uh,
the tsar and his wife believed a naive Lee that they were going to be,
um,
taken to Moscow because Krinsky wanted,
uh,
because of the provisional government,
wanted,
um,
originally,
uh,
before the provisional government has ended a wants to Nicholas to sign the,
the eventual peace treaty,
uh,
with,
the Germans.
Um,
but,
uh,
so,
this,
uh,
Yaakov that was ordered to take his baggage as they called it,
that is the royal family,
uh,
to this small town,
in the year olds in the Ural Mountains.
But the,
you're all,
you're all mountain Bolsheviks were harder to control.
Remember the Russian revolution,
both the first one in the second have been an athlete described as a revolution.
By Telegraph,
I mean the vast reaches of the Russian empire.
So,
absolutely enormous,
uh,
that in many cases,
it was a weeks in a few places,
months before any revolutionary call me.
Sarah arrived to,
to,
uh,
to sort of inform people what's going on.
And so lots of these Bolsheviks were sort of freelancers and for a party that
was extremely hierarchically controlled from the top down,
uh,
there was very little control over,
the Ural,
uh,
Bolsheviks I'm Nicholas had some trepidation about that,
because he heard that there was a quote wrote that there was a mood that was
rather harsh against him.
Uh,
conditions were worse.
they used to like to photograph,
uh,
birds and things like that and bushes and their equipment was taken away from
them.
They could no longer control their own money.
The guards couldn't talk to them at all,
so they can only talk to each other.
Um,
uh,
and some of the guards were,
were,
were just,
just awful to them.
Uh,
there were plans afoot to put them on trial,
the,
a kind of show trial.
Uh,
but there was also this possibility,
uh,
discussed that,
they might,
uh,
simply been,
be killed,
Trotsky ask that they be put on trial so that the corruption and abuses of the
autocracy could be revealed.
Um,
the context is,
is that there are,
you know,
large,
massive,
uh,
armies being organized,
the white armies.
Uh,
and because foreign intervention was already underway,
it's conceivable that,
I mean,
one could imagine a why there was a,
a current,
um,
w national current within the Bolsheviks but local in particular,
and that's what would count that they should be,
uh,
that they should be executed.
It's possible that a telegram came from Moscow ordering that they be executed.
Um,
or simply that it had was a year old.
Bolsheviks you're all the mountains.
You are Aal Bolsheviks acting on their own.
The recently,
you know,
the archives have been opened up only in the last 10 or 15 years.
And the people that have looked,
uh,
think that that is,
mostly,
uh,
the case.
Um,
in any case,
um,
the order came that in July,
1918 that there'd be a trial.
Uh,
but if that was not possible,
deemed possible that they should be shot
a bloody execution.
And the night of a early morning really of July 16th,
17th,
that number again,
they actually died on the 17th of July,
1918 in a,
you know,
a horrific massacre with machine guns and pistols,
a bloodbath in the basement of a house.
Almost immediately there were stories that Alexandra and her daughters had been
a seen taking a train away from their way into the 1980s.
The Russian community,
uh,
in Paris,
tended to settle around the boulevard Montparnasse,
whether it's who's still a very good Russian restaurant,
uh,
that is there.
Um,
and there's a particular cafe called the Coupole were sort of the Russian emigre
wealthy people went and they were periodically women turning up who claimed to
be the daughter.
And then later as the time passed,
the granddaughter of the czar,
it was only after the,
what was left of the bodies are the bones and dry bones were discovered in 1976
and forensic experts in 1991 we're able to work with a DNA that the victims have
all been accounted for.
None of them escaped.
And the others were in that long Russian tradition of faults.
Czars or false Serenas the kind,
the loyalty of who to whom in the 18th century,
January and somebody uprisings.
What can one say?
You know,
they were,
uh,
he's being canonized,
this vicious murderers,
anti-semite by the Russian Orthodox Church.
But that's not my church this off for me to say that.
So I don't know.
It's,
I do know,
but anyway,
tragic mart martyrdom,
you know,
where they,
heroic people or simply human beings who are mowed down in a revolution,
a revolution that,
that,
uh,
it didn't start out as a bloody revolution,
but became a very,
very bloody civil war.
Was that the first sign posts of Soviet totalitarianism?
No,
it wasn't.
That was a bloody vengeance for past misdeeds and the pursuit of justice.
It depends on your viewpoint.
I happen to believe the ladder.
See on Wednesday.
Thank you.